We get support from UC Davis, a globally ranked university, working to solve the world's most pressing problems in food, energy, health, education, and the environment. UC Davis researchers collaborate and innovate in California and around the globe to find transformational solutions. It's all part of the university's mission to promote quality of life for all living things. Find out more at 21stCentury.ucdavis.edu. This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. In the center of San Francisco, there's a plaza with no benches. Its central feature at the entrance of the plaza is a unique fountain that was designed by Lawrence Halbrun in 1975.
我们得到了加州大学戴维斯分校的支持。这是一所全球知名的大学，致力于解决当今世界在食品、能源、健康、教育和环境领域最紧迫的问题。加州大学戴维斯分校的研究人员在加州乃至全球各地合作创新，寻找变革性的解决方案。这完全符合该大学为所有生命提升生活品质的使命。了解更多信息，请访问 21stCentury.ucdavis.edu。这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯。在旧金山市中心，有一个没有长椅的广场。它位于广场入口处的标志性景观是一个独特的喷泉，由劳伦斯·哈尔普林于1975年设计。
The water shoots out at various angles from inside, a sunken pit filled with large granite slabs. It's a design that kind of pulls you in and invites you to take the steps down to the water and climb in between the hulking stones. And that's part of the problem. In 2004, radio producer Ben Tempton created a really fantastic documentary at UN Plaza called the biography of a hundred thousand square feet that first aired on a radio program I produced called Invisible Ink in May of 2004. The doc takes this really hard look at UN Plaza when it was at its absolute worst.
水柱从一个内陷的、填满大型花岗岩板的凹坑中从内部以各种角度喷涌而出。这种设计有点像在吸引你，邀请你走下台阶走向水边，并在那些笨重的石块之间穿梭。而这正是问题所在。2004年，广播制作人本·坦普顿在联合国广场制作了一部非常精彩的纪录片，名为《十万平方英尺的传记》，该片于2004年5月在我制作的名为《隐形墨水》的广播节目中首播。这部纪录片对当时处于绝对谷底的联合国广场进行了非常严厉审视。
And asks, what I think is a really interesting question. Is there a point where good intentions and idealism of a certain design become so removed from reality that it actually borders on negligence? Alright, here's the show. I like to think my pal Ben Tempton for giving me the honor of premiering the piece back in 2004 and then letting me play it for you again more than seven years later as part of 99% Invisible. Things have changed a bit since the stock was produced, so stay tuned and I'll give you
并提出了我认为非常有趣的问题。当某种设计的良好意愿和理想主义与现实脱节到一定程度时，它是否实际上已经接近于渎职的边缘？好了，节目开始了。我要感谢我的老朋友本·坦普顿，他让我有幸在2004年首播这部作品，并在七年多后让我作为《99% Invisible》的一部分再次为您播放。自从这部纪录片制作以来，情况发生了一些变化，所以请继续收听，我将在节目之后为您提供
a short update on you and Plaza after the piece. Here's Ben Tempton. This is the biography of a hundred thousand square feet. At the heart of San Francisco, there is a crossroads where Market Street meets the Civic Center. It is called United Nations Plaza or less formally, Urination Plaza. And for most of the past three decades, it has been San Francisco's most public theater of squalor, misery, and sickness. That place you in Plaza was a madhouse.
关于联合国广场的简短更新。接下来是本·坦普顿。这是《十万平方英尺的传记》。在旧金山市中心，有一个十字路口，马基特街与市民中心在此交汇。它被称为联合国广场，或者不太正式地被称为排泄物广场。在过去三十年的大部分时间里，这里一直是旧金山最公开的肮脏、苦难和疾病的剧场。那个地方，联合国广场，就像一个疯人院。
You could go there any hour of the day, and see needles, liquor bottles, people fighting, people urinating and defecating in that fountain there, that that's unsanitary. I've seen people shoot up at one end and go to the other end and die. I saw that. It's not Italy. People don't stroll down streets and sit and you know, and play bachou, it's just not the mentality to use these big wide open plazas. It's never worked.
你一天中的任何小时去那里，都能看到针头、酒瓶，有人在打架，有人在那座喷泉里小便和大便，这太不卫生了。我曾看到有人在一头注射毒品，然后走到另一头死去。我亲眼见过。这里不是意大利。人们不会漫步街头、坐下来玩地掷球，人们根本没有利用这些宽阔开放广场的心态。这从来都没有行通。
I worked in UN plaza for a summer, walked across the brick paving through the wide view to San Francisco's imposing city hall. Pass passed the granite fountain protected by a yellow plastic chain through the thicket of the dull-eyed crack smokers and dealers who circled among the bronze stumps, all that's left to the benches since they cut them out with saws and removed them. I started spending time in United Nations on my days off talking to the people there. The question I was after was, why does a public space fail? Derek Armstrong was there most days I was. Derek was enormous, weighed at least 400 pounds, and he sat on the planter bet walls every day,
我在联合国广场工作过一个夏天，踩着砖砌路面，穿过开阔的视野，走向旧金山雄伟的市政厅。走过那座被黄色塑料链条保护的花岗岩喷泉，穿过那些眼神呆滞的吸毒者和毒贩的丛林——他们围着那些青铜树桩转悠，而这些树桩就是当年锯掉并移走长椅后仅存的东西。我开始在休息日花时间去联合国广场，和那里的人交谈。我追寻的问题是：为什么一个公共空间会失败？我去的绝大多数日子，德里克·阿姆斯特朗都在那里。德里克体型庞大，至少有400磅重，他每天都坐在花坛矮墙上，
eating from bags of cheetos and listening to his radio. I asked him, why do you come down to UN Plaza? UN Plaza is centrally located to a lot of homers' services that are you, the manless and an activist. UN Plaza is on the glide path between two of San Francisco's poorest neighborhoods, the tenderloin and so much. UN Plaza is on the glide path between two of San Francisco's poorest neighborhoods, the tenderloin and so much. UN Plaza is on the glide path between two of San Francisco's poorest neighborhoods, the tenderloin and so much.
吃着一袋袋奇多，听着收音机。我问他，你为什么来联合国广场？联合国广场处于中心位置，离许多为无家可归者提供服务的机构很近，你是无家可归者，也是个活动家。联合国广场位于旧金山两个最贫困社区——田德隆区和索玛区——之间的必经路线上。联合国广场位于旧金山两个最贫困社区——田德隆区和索玛区——之间的必经路线上。联合国广场位于旧金山两个最贫困社区——田德隆区和索玛区——之间的必经路线上。
UN Plaza is on the glide path between two of San Francisco's poorest neighborhoods, the tenderloin and so much. UN Plaza is on the glide path between two of San Francisco's poorest neighborhoods, the tenderloin and so much. One Saturday, I went down to watch some evangelists preach to the lost souls in United Nations Plaza. One of the preachers used to be homeless there himself. Off, away from the main body of the audience, I saw a man sitting against the black metal poles circling the fountain.
联合国广场位于旧金山两个最贫困社区——田德隆区和索玛区——之间的必经路线上。联合国广场位于旧金山两个最贫困社区——田德隆区和索玛区——之间的必经路线上。一个星期六，我去了那里，看一些传教士向联合国广场上迷失的灵魂传教。其中一位传教士自己以前也曾无家可归。在远离主体人群的地方，我看到一个男人靠着环绕喷泉的黑色铁柱坐着。
He was behind the preachers and their loudspeakers watching, and I asked him, why are you sitting over here and not over there? Because I don't want to partake in anything right now. I'm pretty much closed myself away from everything. His name is Wendell Edwards. I got arrested for sleeping on the sidewalk and let out the same day. And I lost a lot of love for the United States flag behind that. Because they made me feel like an enemy, like I was part of a Taliban or something.
他坐在传教士和他们的扬声器后面看着，我问他，你为什么坐在这一边而不是那边？因为我现在不想参与任何事情。我已经把自己同外界的一切基本上都隔绝了。他的名字叫温德尔·爱德华兹。我因为睡在人行道上而被捕，但同一天就被释放了。为此我对美国国旗失去了很多好感。因为他们让我觉得自己像个敌人，就像我是塔利班的一员或者别的什么。
And my father died fighting for this country. So when I was arrested, that mentally really hurt me against the flag because I could have been breaking in somebody called. I could have been hurting any of these people and taking a wallet at night, catching them coming out of the store or house or anything. And I did none of that. It wasn't in my heart to do that, but it wasn't in my heart to arrest me for sleeping, merely sleeping on the sidewalk, and I'll never forget that.
而我的父亲曾为这个国家浴血奋战。所以当我被捕时，那种精神上的打击让我对国旗产生了反感，因为我当时本可以去闯入别人的住所。我本可以伤害这些人中的任何一个，在夜里抢他们的钱包，在他们从商店或房子出来时下手，或者干别的什么。但我什么都没做。我心里没想过要这么做，但他们因为睡觉——仅仅是在人行道上睡觉——而逮捕我，这可不是我心甘情愿的，我永远不会忘记这一点。
I still got to take it in my pocket. It was just last week. And the devil keep telling me that, since that happened, don't you see what they trying to do to you? Go out and pay them back. Go rob a store. Because you don't have no flag. You don't have no country, you don't have nothing.
我至今还得把它揣在口袋里。就在上星期。魔鬼一直对我说，既然发生了这种事，难道你没看到他们在对你做什么吗？出去报复他们吧。去抢劫一家商店。因为你没有国旗。你没有国家，你什么都没有。
They don't want you to be a part of it. That's just a nice word of saying, nigga, get out of San Francisco. How did it get this bad? How did a space commemorating one of the great institutions in human history? At the heart of the richest city and the richest country in history, a place of so much promise turned out so wrong. My assignment was to develop Market Street over again as a new promenade from the ferry building to the city hall. This is Lawrence Halperin.
他们不想让你成为其中一部分。这不过是委婉地对你说：黑鬼，滚出旧金山。事情怎么会变成这样？一个纪念人类历史上伟大机构之一的空间怎么会变成这样？在历史最富有的城市和最富有的国家的中心，一个充满无限希望的地方怎么会错得如此离谱？我的任务是重新开发马基特街，将其打造为从轮渡大厦到市政厅的新步行长廊。这是劳伦斯·哈尔普林。
My idea and the whole idea for the city and our team and design was to make a formal entrance to City Hall that people would admire and would perceive as an important part of the formal quality of the downtown area, like Paris. Have you ever been to Paris? In 1972, the city spent $24 million beautifying market street, which had been torn up for the installation of a subway system. The final section of the redesign was United Nations Plaza.
我的想法，以及城市和我们整个设计团队的整体构想，是为市政厅打造一个正式的入口，人们会对此赞叹不已，并将其视为市中心正式格调的重要组成部分，就像巴黎那样。你去过巴黎吗？1972年，该市斥资2400万美元美化马基特街，该街道此前因修建地铁系统而被彻底挖开。重新设计的最后一部分就是联合国广场。
The city hired Halperin to make the design. There is this quality of formality that we were after, and expressive the culture of the city. That was what we were thinking about. The importance of linear visual experiences. The linking of one place to another, instead of the kind of informality of neighborhoods where little streets go wandering around and you don't get any long views. Lawrence Halperin is one of the most celebrated landscape architects alive today. He has
该市聘请哈尔普林来进行设计。我们追求的是这种正式感，以及对城市文化的表达。这正是我们当时所思考的。线性视觉体验的重要性。将一个地方与另一个地方连接起来，而不是那种社区的非正式感——在那里小街道四处蜿蜒，你看不到开阔的远景。劳伦斯·哈尔普林是当今在世最著名的景观设计师之一。他
been awarded the Presidential Medal of the Arts, he designed the FDR Memorial in Washington, DC, he designed the promenade around Jerusalem. He has designed some of the most noted and famous public plazas in the country. We wanted to make a statement there in a Greek sense. The visual qualities have to express what the politics of something are. Not a little sort of political, this is, and that's, it's a major quality of what a city ought to be like and what it stands for as a government.
曾被授予总统国家艺术勋章，他设计了华盛顿特区的罗斯福纪念馆，他设计了耶路撒冷周围的长廊。他设计了国内一些最受瞩目、最著名的公共广场。我们希望在那里以古希腊的理念做出一番表态。视觉品质必须表达某种事物的政治属性。这不仅仅是某种微不足道的政治表态，而是一个城市应该是什么样子的核心品质，以及它作为一个政府所代表的立场。
Was it called United Nations President? Hell no, there wasn't anything like that. City planners designated the space UN Plaza after the decision was made to close the intersection. The intersection was closed because of a unique aspect of the city's urban design. Peter Bosselman, chair of the Department of Urban Planning at the University of California explains. There's a peculiar geometry about San Francisco. Market Street was lined up to connect the waterfront with a set of hills called Twin Peaks.
它叫联合国广场吗？见鬼，才没有那回事。在决定关闭该交叉路口后，城市规划者将该空间命名为联合国广场。该路口之所以被关闭，是因为该市城市设计的一个独特性质。加州大学城市规划系主任彼得·博塞尔曼进行了解释。旧金山有着奇特的几何结构。马基特街的走向将海滨与一组被称为双子峰的山丘连接起来。
But it is not a aligned to the city grid. Market street runs at a 45-degree angle, creating all kinds of strange intersections where streets enter Market Street never 90-degree angles, always 45-degree angle. And even for San Francisco's is very confusing to find the connection between the south of Market Grid and the north of Market Grid. Very few streets line up. The design Halpern came up with for United Nations was a stately gateway for marches to pass through. The marchers would be funneled from the wide edge of the plaza
但它与城市网格并不对齐。马基特街以45度的角度延伸，创造了各种奇怪的交叉口，街道进入马基特街时绝不是90度角，永远是45度角。即使对旧金山人来说，要找到马基特街以南网格和马基特街以北网格之间的连接也非常令人困惑。极少数街道是对齐的。哈尔普林为联合国广场构思的设计是一座庄严的门户，供游行队伍穿过。游行队伍将从广场宽阔的边缘被引导通过
that runs along Market Street between two lines of trees and raised planar beds, and then out through the space between the library and the Asian Art Museum to the vast green lawns of Civic Center Plaza. This centerpiece is the 165-foot-long fountain. It contains 673 blocks of granite, weighing somewhere between 3 and 4 million tons. I took the idea of the high seara surrounding the bay itself, and down in here you can see the bay.
该边缘沿马基特街延伸，介于两行树木和抬高的花坛之间，然后通过图书馆与亚洲艺术博物馆之间的空间，通往市民中心广场广阔的绿色草坪。核心景观是长达165英尺的喷泉。它包含673块花岗岩，重量在300万到400万吨之间。我借用了环绕海湾本身的内海滩（High Sierra）的创意，在这里你可以看到海湾。
And I even developed a system of the tides coming in. There was an hour-long tidal action where the tide was out and then it lardged in, grew, and grew till it was up on these peaks. What you see in other words is a three-dimensional plaza, which is unique as an idea. Does that happen now? This tidal system no longer exists because maintenance was so terrible and it's going to hell. Pumps are a lot like relationships between people unless you take care of them, they go to hell. The fountain design was not immediately popular with city planners. In December 1970, the chairman of the Civic Design Committee said it was awful, flamboyant, an example of a designer's egotism being passed on to the people as a piece of art.
我甚至开发了一个潮汐涨落系统。这是一个持续一小时的潮汐动作，潮水退去，然后涌进来，不断上涨、扩大，直到漫上这些山峰。换句话说，你看到的是一个三维广场，这作为一个创意是独一无二的。现在这种情况还存在吗？这个潮汐系统已经不复存在了，因为维护工作太糟糕了，它已经变得一团糟。水泵就像人与人之间的关系一样，除非你精心照料，否则它们就会走向毁灭。喷泉的设计并没有立刻受到城市规划者的欢迎。1970年12月，市民设计委员会的主席称其为可怕的、浮夸的，是设计师的利己主义作为一件艺术品强加给人们的例证。
Ruth Asawa, an acclaimed San Francisco sculptor, said, As corny as this may sound, you have to design places in the city for people to sit on the grass, sit under trees, for flowers and birds. Even Herb Cain got into it when he called the fountain a monstrosity that must be stopped. But after five years of planning and arguing, it was built anyway. Chris Adams has worked in the plaza for more than 20 years.
旧金山广受赞誉的雕塑家露丝·阿萨瓦说：听起来可能很老套，你必须在城市里为人们设计可以坐在草地上、坐在树荫下、有花有鸟的地方。甚至赫伯·凯恩也参与进来，称该喷泉是一个必须被阻止的怪物。但经过五年的规划和争论，它还是被建造了。克里斯·亚当斯在广场工作了二十多年。
When that fountain blew water, it was supposed to work with the wind. If the wind blew too far, the water was supposed to go down. I've been here since that fountain was put in and I've never ever seen it work correctly. It's blowing 50 feet in the air in the winter and the water is just pouring and the fact that it did start to stink. The chemicals that were put in there killed all the trees that were around it. Children wanted to play in there and of course you don't want kids in that water.
当年这个喷泉喷水时，它本该是随风调节的。如果风吹得太猛，水流本该减弱。自从这个喷泉建成以来我就在这里，但我从来没有见过它正常运作过。冬天它能喷到50英尺高的空中，水到处流淌，而且它开始发臭了。投入其中的化学物质杀死了周围所有的树木。孩子们想在里面玩，当然你不会希望孩子们待在那样的水里。
Many of the worries expressed by critics of the design quickly came to pass. In June of 1979, less than a year after the fountain was completed, a columnist for the San Francisco Examiner wrote an article about the Vandals, derelicts and social misfits who were turning the space into a garbage strewn graffitioned graffiti-de-faced mockery of Civic Granger. Kevin Star wrote, what should have been the new triumphant entrance to our Civic Center is a resort for derelicts and bombs. Merchants.
设计批评者所表达的许多担忧很快就成为了现实。1979年6月，在喷泉完工还不到一年的时候，《旧金山考察报》的一位专栏作家发表了一篇文章，痛斥那些将这个空间变成垃圾遍地、涂鸦横陈、对市民尊严的嘲弄的破坏分子、流浪汉和社会边缘人。凯文·斯塔尔写道：“本应作为我们市民中心崭新而凯旋般的入口，如今却成了流浪汉和懒汉的度假村。商人们……”
All along Market Street, how great hope that the transformation of Market Street would occur. And it never happened. Things went the other way. Bob Prentice was the director of Homeless Services under Mayor Art Agnos from 1988 to 1992. The merchants were extremely frustrated because of these you know these frustrated expectations that took the form of now people actually hanging out in the plaza. It was just a tender box. That was the environment of
整个马基特街沿线的商户都抱着巨大的希望，以为马基特街的转型会带来好运。但这一切从未发生。情况走向了反面。鲍勃·普伦蒂斯在1988年至1992年阿特·阿格诺斯市长任内担任无家可归者服务局局长。商人们极其沮丧，因为这些幻灭的期望最终演变成人们开始真正在广场上闲逛。这里简直就是个火药桶。这就是
the UN plaza pretty much from the time that I started working in the plaza. It was just a tender box. That was the environment of UN Plaza pretty much from the time that I started working in the mayor's office. In 1980, the Market Street Association, an organization of business owners and property owners called for a farmers market to be put in UN Plaza. Chris Adams runs the farmers market. I know it wasn't raining, it was a nice sunny day,
联合国广场的环境，几乎从我开始在广场工作时起就是这样。这简直是一个火药桶。从我开始在市长办公室工作起，联合国广场的环境基本上就是这样。1980年，由企业主和业主组成的组织——马基特街协会呼吁在联合国广场建立一个农夫市场。克里斯·亚当斯负责运营这个农夫市场。我记得那天没下雨，是个晴朗的好日子，
1980, 81. And I believe it was springtime. Twelve farmers drove up with their trucks and they did not sell out, but as they came weekly, we just put our roots down there and we're here to stay. There were some people in the neighborhood who were trying to think of ways to heal the plaza, and the farmer's market was part of that. Poor people are here. It's harder for them to get by. It's not about, you know, driving them away. It's about civilizing the places where they live. They can come out. They can breathe out there. It is part of the tenderloin. That's their front room. I've been told that by almost all of this is our place.
1980年或81年。我记得那是春天。十二位农民开着卡车来到这里，他们并没有卖光所有东西，但随着他们每周都来，我们就在这里扎下了根，并且会一直留在这里。社区里有一些人正试图寻找治愈广场的方法，而农夫市场就是其中的一部分。穷人们就在这里。他们要维系生计更加艰难。这并不是要把他们赶走。这是关于让人们居住的地方变得更有教化。他们可以出来。他们可以在那里自由呼吸。这里是田德隆区的一部分。那是他们的前厅。几乎所有人都这么对我说：这是我们的地方。
You can see the refrigerators, couches, chairs. They do live down there. I don't want to push them out of there. I just share it. Bob Prentice again. It was a way to take over some use of that plaza with a purpose that supported everybody. The idea that you would bring a farmer's market
你可以看到冰箱、沙发、椅子。他们确实住在那里。我不想把他们赶出去。我只是与他们共享这个地方。再次引用鲍勃·普伦蒂斯的话。这是一种通过服务于大众的目的来接管广场部分使用权的方式。把农夫市场带到
to the heart of the city where there was no retail grocer, where people who lived on the lowest incomes could not get decent food at decent prices. You see, to me, that's the spirit behind, you know, dealing with the seeming and avidability of poverty without being mean-spirited about it. Chris Adams, the director of the farmer's market.
市中心的想法——那里没有零售杂货店，收入最低的人无法以合理的价格买到像样的食物。你看，对我国而言，这就是以不刻薄的方式去应对贫困这一看似不可避免的问题背后的精神。克里斯·亚当斯，农夫市场的负责人。
I've been homeless. When? 1970? I lived in a car for two weeks with my kids. There was no way I was going to stay like that. That's one reason I was hired. Not that I could do office work, but I got along with the people outside. I can get along with all the nationalities.
我曾无家可归过。什么时候？1970年？我和孩子们在车里住了两个星期。我绝不可能那样一直过下去。这也是我被录用的原因之一。并不是因为我会做办公室工作，而是我能和外面的人相处融洽。我能和所有国籍的人打成一片。
I enjoy it. I think it's fine as a place that occurs every now and then. You think it's a good use of this space? Yes, I do. On Wednesdays, office workers in the Beseesh neighborhood skip microwave lunches, gobbled at their desks, and head out instead to the heart of the city farmer's market. On Sundays, it's a neighborhood crowd moving between the white tents that fill the
我很享受这份工作。我觉得作为一个偶尔举办的场所，这里挺好的。你认为对这个空间的使用是合理的吗？是的，我这么认为。星期三，生计区（SoMa）的办公室职员会跳过在办公桌狼吞虎咽的微波午餐，转而前往市中心的农夫市场。星期天，则是周边社区的居民穿梭于填满整个广场的
plaza. Folding tables covered with yellow squash, blueberries, salad greens, all organic. The customers are from all over. The farmers are from all over. That's why I love being where we are. I mean, Cambodia, Vietnam, Mexico, Italy, all over the world. The heart of the city was a perfect name for it because I thought that solution demonstrated a kind of heart.
白色帐篷之间。折叠桌上摆满了黄南瓜、蓝莓、沙拉绿叶菜，全部都是有机蔬菜。顾客来自四面八方。农民也来自四面八方。这就是为什么我热爱我们所处的位置。我的意思是，柬埔寨、越南、墨西哥、意大利，来自世界各地。市中心（Heart of the City）是个完美的名字，因为我认为那个解决方案展现了一种人情味。
And I think there wasn't tension between the street people and the ones that ran the market. I remember that, but you know we worked that through. You think, you know, this is a civil way to make do with a situation that so far has been pretty lousy. Oh my gosh, it's United Nations. But on days when the farmer's market and the newer, less successful, antique, slash, flea market aren't in the plaza, United Nations reverts to what it used to be.
我认为街头流浪者和运营市场的人之间并没有什么紧张关系。我记得这一点，但你知道的，我们最终解决了。你会觉得，这是一个以文明方式处理迄今为止相当糟糕的局面的方法。哦天哪，这里可是联合国广场。但在没有农夫市场以及较新且不太成功的古董兼跳蚤市场开张的日子里，联合国广场又恢复了它原有的面貌。
At the east end of the plaza, between the glass windows of the fast food franchise and stairs down into the subway station, the thieves marked it moves in. Black market salesmen filled the 20 feet with neatly laid out clothes, hand tools, pornographic videos, and consumer electronics of questionable provenance. Two days before Thanksgiving,
在广场东端，快餐店的玻璃窗和通往地铁站的楼梯之间，黑市交易开始了。黑市小贩用整齐摆放的衣物、手工具、色情录像带以及来源可疑的消费电子产品占据了二十英尺的空地。感恩节前两天，
I went down to the plaza to ask the salesman what have you got to sell today? I got the sweater, a purple sweater, and I got glasses, I got hat, I got a new pair of underpants, I got shoes and I got jacket and I got a woman's blouse. My name is Zachary, I was born of Intura, but I came down here about 15 years ago and lived here ever since. My mother died in January and like, and what's that March? It started like, you know, go gambling. And I lost all my money so I'm out here now.
我走到广场上问小贩们：今天有什么好卖的？我有一件毛衣，一件紫色的毛衣，我还有眼镜、帽子、一条全新的内裤、鞋子、夹克和一件女式衬衫。我叫扎卡里，我在安图拉出生，但大约15岁来到这里，并一直住到现在。我母亲在一月份去世了，然后呢，三月份怎么样？生活开始变得像是去赌博。我把所有的钱都输光了，所以我现在只能流落街头。
I was just choosing everything to me, you know? And I, I took it out by Gamla. And somewhat, you know, cursing God. While we were talking, the drug addicts distinguishable from the merely homeless by their lack of luggage began to line up against the windows of the Carl's Jr. Look, everybody's all lined up. Why are they all lined up? I have no idea. Why are they lined up? Oh, I don't know. He's leading. That guy with the dreadlocks is taking blood off his nose and now they're putting that guy in hand. That's what makes them say,
对我来说，一切都像是在走下坡路，你知道吗？我被赌博害惨了。而且不知怎么的，你知道的，还在怨恨上帝。正当我们谈话时，那些因没有行李而很容易与普通无家可归者区分开来的瘾君子们开始在卡尔史翠基（Carl's Jr.）快餐店的窗户前排起长队。瞧，大家都排起队了。他们为什么都在排队？我毫无头破。他们为什么在排队？哦，我不知道。他在指挥。那个留着脏辫的家伙在擦鼻子，现在他们把那个人给按住了。这就是让他们说出
okay, they're uncivilized. Yeah, the guy must have punched the guy. That's sad. So you're going to clear up? Yeah, I got to go down the way. As Zachary packed up his meager merchandise, I went to find out what was going on. A tourist had bought food at the Carl's Jr. to give away to the homeless.
“好吧，他们真是不文明”的原因。是的，那家伙肯定打了那个人。真可悲。所以你要去清理了吗？对，我得去那边了。正当扎卡里打包他那点可怜的商品时，我走过去查看发生了什么事。一名游客在卡尔史翠基买了食物分发给无家可归者。
My name is Kadeezha Morris. My intention to be in California is to buy two big buildings to take the homeless off the street. It's hard to explain. It's a dream I had. And it's coming to pass. I've been driving around this block twice. And this was the sign the people in front of Cal Junior. So I know this was the place to rest. People were lining up. Everybody outside please. Somebody talk to him, go and drop it on the ground.
我叫卡迪莎·莫里斯。我来加州的打算是买两栋大楼，把无家可归者从街上接走。这很难解释。这是我做的一个梦。而且它正在实现。我已经绕着这个街区转了两圈了。这就是卡尔史翠基门前人们的标志。所以我知道这里就是休息的地方。人们正在排队。外面的人请注意。谁去跟他说说，把东西往地上一扔。
As the manager tried to bring the food out. I give it to you, Ordon, you got the food right? There's now, nothing but this one. This is the seven police officers. When he got outside, the line collapse, order broke down completely. You got a small riot out here and it's a different thing. A woman got smacked. No grabbing, no touching. You want to do that?
正当经理试图把食物拿出来时。我把它交给你，奥登，你拿到食物了吧？现在，只有这个了。这里有七个警察。当他走到外面时，队伍崩溃了，秩序彻底瓦解。这外面发生了一场小型骚乱，情况完全不同。有个女人挨了巴掌。不准抢，不准碰。你想这么干？
And he must go do it. You guys be civil, he doesn't have to do this. One team in the line, right behind, right behind. You see how it is? I mean, a little man, it goes the wrong way. This is Mohammed, the manager of the Carl's Junior. I mean, we try to serve the food to the hungry, homeless people. Then I told him, go wait outside on the line,
他非得这么干不可。你们文明点，他本不必这么做的。队伍排好，就在后面，就在后面。你看情况是怎样的？我是说，一个细小的失误，事情就走向了反面。这是穆罕默德，卡尔史翠基的经理。我是说，我们试图把食物分发给饥饿、无家可归的人。然后我告诉他们，去外面排队，
so as soon as I get ready, I will be outside. They start fighting together. I don't know why they start fighting. When I came outside, and they start grabbing the food from the boxes, as soon as we came out with the boxes, everybody jumped on us. And two minutes, all the food is gone. In miniature, this food riot restates the failure of UN Plaza itself,
这样我一准备好就会出去。他们开始互相打斗。我不知道他们为什么开始打斗。当我走出来时，他们开始从盒子里抢食物。我们刚把箱子拿出来，每个人都扑向我们。两分钟内，所有的食物就被抢光了。这场微型的食物骚乱重现了联合国广场自身的失败，
a dream that proved no match for its burden. Palprin II had a vision for something decent, of the grace of public spaces. But when this dream was overlaid on a real place, it just didn't work out. I'm not sure even now if I were gonna be asked to design this, how much I would change? Really? I mean, why would I, you're talking about my life's work
一个事实证明根本无法承载其重负的梦想。哈尔普林也曾对体面的事物、对公共空间的优雅抱有愿景。但当这个梦想被叠加在一个现实的地方时，结果却行不通了。即使是现在，如果有人让我重新设计这个地方，我也不确定自己会改变多少。真的吗？我的意思是，为什么不呢？你谈论的是我毕生的心血，
for Christ's sakes. I was the first person who ever designed a plaza and found so that people could use it. People should not be told you can't get inside of it and use it. All places should be usable by people in the city. Now having said that, why would I design something to prevent homelessness? I mean, homelessness is a social problem that cannot be designed for and in the sense of aesthetics and culture. Of course they should be friendly. The real question is
看在上帝的份上。我是第一个设计广场并将其设计成人们可以使用的人。人们不应该被告知你不能进去使用它。所有的场所都应该供城市里的居民使用。话虽如此，我为什么要设计一个能阻止无家可归现象的东西呢？我是说，无家可归是一个社会问题，是无法通过美学和文化的审美设计来解决的。当然它们应该是友好的。真正的问题是
what do you mean by friendly? Nobody has ever said to me I want you to design an unfriendly place. But you know it depends on who you talk to. I mean when you say you've talked to people who say that sort of thing, oh, who are they? Sounds like a pretty stupid thing to say, actually. I would absolutely challenge it. I can't imagine that anybody could say anything like that. In 2000, the Department of Public Works applied for and was awarded federal grant money to clean up the 28-year-old plaza,
你所说的友好是什么意思？从来没有人对我说过：我想让你设计一个不友好的地方。但你知道的，这取决于你跟谁谈。我是说，当你谈到你和那些说过这种话的人交谈过时，哦，他们是谁？听起来真是一件挺蠢的话语，说实话。我绝对会提出质疑。我无法想象任何人会说出这样的话。2000年，公共工程局申请并获得了联邦拨款，用于清理这个建于28年前的广场，
almost a million dollars, enough to make real changes to the design. This is Judy Mosqueda, a project manager for the Department of Public Works. I first got to know United Nations Plaza back in 1979. I used to take part into the plaza with my sister. I was about 12 years old. I was not a fast walker, and I remember so vividly, my sister walking as fast as she could up 11 more street because there were men harassing us
近百万美元资金，足以对设计做出实质性的改变。这是朱迪·莫斯奎达，公共工程局的项目经理。我第一次认识联合国广场是在1979年。我过去常常和姐姐一起去广场。我当时大约12岁。我走路不快，我记得非常清楚，我姐姐沿着第11街拼命地往前走，因为有一路上有男人在骚扰我们，
along the way, and I would have to jog alongside her to keep up with her, and that was embarrassing to me. When Judy came on as project manager, a plan for the redesign had already been drawn up. Landscape architects here at the Department of Public Works had made some recommendations for improvements to it. Things like replanting the planter beds with flowers instead of the grass that's there now.
我不得不跟在她旁边慢跑才能跟上，这让我感到很尴尬。当朱迪接任项目经理时，重新设计的方案已经绘制好了。公共工程局的景观设计师对该方案提出了一些改进建议。比如用花卉重新种植花坛，而不是现在那片草坪。
Something that would add color a little bit of life to the plaza. As we went to the Board of Supervisors, the fencing around the planters became a contentious issue. In December 2001, the plan drawn up by DPW was rejected by the board of supervisors. They didn't like the fences. A 15 member task force was created by the city. The task force asked Roma design to make some recommendations. This is Boris Dramov, a principal at
那样能为广场增添色彩和一点生机。当我们去到监事会时，花坛周围的围栏成了一个颇具争议的问题。2001年12月，公共工程局绘制的方案被监事会否决了。他们不喜欢那些围栏。城市成立了一个由15人组成的特别工作组。该工作组邀请罗马设计公司（Roma Design）提出一些建议。这是鲍里斯·德拉莫夫，
Roma. The mayor's office, he was not too pleased with what was being proposed. And I said, there are the standard kinds of things to prevent people from using space. The first step is you take out the benches, then you put little fences around the green areas, then you put barriers for people, so they can't sit down.
罗马设计公司的负责人。市长办公室对当时提出的方案并不是很满意。我说，这些都是阻止人们使用空间的常规手段。第一步是移走长椅，然后你在绿化区周围围上小栅栏，接着为人们设置障碍，这样他们就无法坐下来。
And I said, frankly, I'm not interested in the negative approaches. 15 people with an interest, sometimes competing interests, were appointed by the supervisors to come up with a plan that would fix up the plaza without displacing anyone. The chair was Lynn Valente of the Market Street Association. This is the same Market Street Association that had created the popular farmers market 20 years before. People that are part of Market Street Association that have properties who will live and work up there, their number one request, get that fountain part of market-shoot association that have properties who will live and work
我说，坦白讲，我对这种消极的方法不感兴趣。监事会任命了15名有利害关系的成员（有时这些利益相互冲突），让他们提出一个既能修复广场又不会驱逐任何人的方案。主席是马基特街协会的琳恩·瓦伦蒂。这就是20年前创建了广受欢迎的农夫市场的那个马基特街协会。马基特街协会中那些拥有房产、在那里生活和工作的人，他们的头号诉求就是：把那个喷泉……马基特街协会中那些拥有房产、在那里生活和工作
up there, their number one request, get that fountain out of there. Because people were essentially living in a defecating and urinating in the fountain and shooting up drugs in the fountain, all that kind of stuff, having sex, and I mean they've seen everything. In the end, the task force left Halperin's dream for UN Plaza behind. Roma recommended they removed the fountain, put a street through the thieves' market, in effect, changed United Nations from a formal place, a place for marches, a public square in Halperin's words,
的人，他们的头号诉求就是：把那个喷泉弄走。因为人们基本上就住在喷泉里，在喷泉里大小便，在喷泉里注射毒品，诸如此类的事情，在里面发生性行为，我的意思是他们什么都见过。最终，工作组将哈尔普林对联合国广场的梦想抛在了脑后。罗马设计公司建议移除喷泉，在小偷市场的原址上修一条街，实际上是将联合国广场从一个正式的场所、一个供游行使用的场所、一个用哈尔普林的话说
representative of the ideals of a government and a city, and turned instead to exactly what Halperin didn't want. The informality of neighborhoods where little streets go on during around and you don't get any long views. This is Boris Dramov. This is really a street end that's been closed predominantly for traffic reasons. Fulton Street created a very awkward intersection with Market Street, and traffic engineers don't like triangular intersections, so they tend to eliminate them. Not because they thought it was the best place to create a gathering space.
代表着政府和城市理想的公共广场，变成了一个恰恰是哈尔普林不希望看到的样子。那种社区的非正式感——小街道四处蜿蜒，你看不到开阔的远景。这是鲍里斯·德拉莫夫。这实际上是一条主要是出于交通原因而被封闭的街头死胡同。富尔顿街与马基特街交汇成一个非常尴尬的交叉口，交通工程师不喜欢三角形的交叉口，所以他们倾向于消除它们。并不是因为他们认为这里是创建聚集空间的最佳地点。
One has to question whether there should be an open space of this size and this location. Why would you put it here? In spring of 2003, the plaza hit bottom. The plan drawn up by the task force appointed by the board of supervisors after a year and a half and more than 20 meetings was rejected by the board of supervisors. Around the same time, Channel 4 ran an extremely unflattering news account of the squalor in the plaza. Everywhere you turn, people smoking crack, all day,
人们不得不质疑，在这个位置是否应该有一个如此规模的开放空间。你为什么要把它放在这里？2003年春天，广场跌入了谷底。经过一年半和20多次会议后，由监事会任命的工作组制定的方案被监事会否决了。大约在同一时间，第4频道播出了一个极不美观的新闻报道，讲述了广场上的肮脏状况。无论你转向哪里，都有人一整天、
every day, the mayor says he'll consider shutting down the fountain, removing the benches, and building gated playgrounds. ["Mare Willy Brown's Theme Song"] Within hours, Mayor Willy Brown had made his decision about United Nations plaza. City workers cut through the bronze legs of the 24 benches and by morning they were gone. I think people felt like they lost the battle of you in Plaza.
每一天都在抽快克可卡因，市长表示他将考虑关闭喷泉、移除长椅并建造带栅栏的游乐场。（播放威利·布朗市长竞选主题曲）短短几小时内，威利·布朗市长就对联合国广场做出了决定。市政工人锯断了24张长椅的青铜椅腿，到清晨时分，长椅全部消失了。我想人们觉得他们打输了联合国广场这场战役。
That they're vacating the premises now, that they're taking the benches out. It's contested to rain where they've given up hope they're going to win. Lynn Valenti of the Market Street Association. And we've come up with now after years and years and years of community input, of which I did eight or nine or however many years it is I've been working on. We've got, what we've got now is a caution tape around the fountain. No, it's not caution tape anymore.
他们现在正腾出场地，他们正在把长椅搬走。这是一片他们已经放弃赢得希望的争议领地。马基特街协会的琳恩·瓦伦蒂。经历了一年又一年又一年的社区意见征求后，我们现在得出的结果是——我为之工作了八年、九年或者不管多少年——我们得到了什么，我们现在得到的是缠绕在喷泉周围的警戒线。不，那已经不是警戒线了。
It's a yellow plastic fence. I don't understand how that happened. I mean, I understand how it happened, but it just sticks in my crawl. The first plan that they came up with, the fencing that we were proposing, was no higher than three feet tall. It was not acceptable, then Roma design came in. I'd opened up the street, I'd let people drive down or bicycle down.
那是黄色的塑料栅栏。我不明白这是怎么发生的。我是说，我明白它是怎么发生的，但这让我感到如梗在喉。他们提出的第一个方案中，我们提议的围栏高度不超过三英尺。那不可接受，接着罗马设计公司介入了。我主张开通这条街道，让人们开车或骑自行车穿过。
That was unacceptable, now we're down to the chain link fence around the fountain. And that's how it's been for almost a year. No flowers, no fences, no benches. The crack addicts have mostly been pushed out by the pervasive police presence and the street sweepers that circle constantly like fish and aquarium. The homeless people who used to sit on the planter beds are fewer and numbered, but they're still there. Many of them have shifted 50 feet towards City Hall, where they sit inside a large sculpture of San Francisco's pioneers in the middle of a traffic circle. It would be a stretch to say this is an improvement.
那也是不可接受的，现在我们落得只能在喷泉周围拉铁丝网围栏的下场。差不多一年来一直都是这样。没有鲜花，没有栅栏，也没有长椅。吸毒者大部分已被无处不在的警察以及像水族箱里的鱼一样不断巡逻的清扫车赶走了。那些过去常坐在花坛上的无家可归者人数减少了，但他们依然在那里。他们中的许多人向市政厅方向挪动了50英尺，坐在交通环岛中央一座巨大的旧金山先驱者雕塑里面。硬说这是一个改进，未免有些勉强。
Have you been to United Nations Plaza recently? Have you seen? No, I purposely don't go there usually. Have you seen the pictures of the chain leg fence around the fountain? No, I know about it, though. The city and the project manager for that project has been very careful about keeping us advised
你最近去过联合国广场吗？你看到了吗？没有，我通常故意不去那里。你见过喷泉周围拉着铁丝网围栏的照片吗？没有，不过我知道这件事。市政府和该项目的项目经理一直在非常谨慎地向我们通报
about what's going on. He's trying to recapture some of the original quality of the place and also deal with some of the social issues and neighborhoods that are encroaching on the place. I think some people want to turn that into something it's never going to be. It's not going to be a renaissance. That's not going to happen.
进展情况。他试图重现该地方最初的一些品质，同时也处理一些侵蚀该地方的社会问题和社区问题。我认为有些人想把它变成它永远不可能成为的样子。它不会迎来文艺复兴。那是不可能的。
I mean, this is part of the tenderloin, and that influence is always going to be there. I'm sorry, but I think that's how it should be. I really do. Why do you cut off the daily life of the city in order to create a space for special events that only occur a few times a year. I would question whether we should have an open space
我的意思是，这是田德隆区的一部分，这种影响将永远存在。我很抱歉，但我认为它本该如此。我真的是这么想的。为什么要为了创造一个一年只举办几次特殊活动的场所，而去切断城市的日常生活呢。我要质疑的是，在这个位置我们是否应该有一个如此规模的开放空间，
of this size at this location, rather than allowing the traditional elements of city form, like streets, sidewalks to exist. Judy Mosqueda is optimistic, but it is a resigned optimism. The funds were to be expended by, I believe, June 2003. Obviously, I've missed that deadline. I'm now shooting for June 2005, and I hope
而不是让城市形态的传统要素（如街道、人行道）存在下去。朱迪·莫斯奎达保持着乐观，但那是一种无奈的乐观。这些资金本应在2003年6月之前花掉。很明显，我错过了那个截止日期。我现在把目标定在2005年6月，我希望
to be successful for that. And if San Francisco's can't come to consensus on what should happen in this plaza, I may ask for another extension, or we may decide that San Francisco doesn't know what to do with this plaza at I may ask for another extension, or we may decide that San Francisco doesn't know what to do with this plaza at this point in time. Before San Francisco gives up on United Nations plaza, we might want to consider some words of advice given by President Harry Truman when the charter for the real United Nations
能够成功。如果旧金山人无法就这个广场应该发生什么达成共识，我可能会要求再次延期，或者我们可能会决定旧金山目前还不知道该如何处理这个广场。或者我们可能会决定旧金山目前还不知道该如何处理这个广场。在旧金山放弃联合国广场之前，我们或许应该考虑一下近60年前真正的联合国宪章签署时，哈里·杜鲁门总统给出的一些忠告。
was signed almost 60 years ago. Oh, what a great day this can be in history. On all the arguments and disputes and different points of view, a way was found to agree. Truman is speaking to the delegates who would sign the UN Charter in the war memorial opera house. Six blocks away from the present day, United Nations Plaza. It was the result of a spirit of give and take of tolerance for the views and interests present day United Nations Plaza. We keep to our principles, and never forsake our objectives, the problems we now face, produced by Ben Tempton in 2004. I'm recording this on November 17, 2011, and I was down at UN Plaza today recording the fountain and taking pictures.
哦，今天是历史上多么伟大的一天。在所有的争论、争端和不同的观点中，人们找到了达成一致的方法。杜鲁门在距离现代联合国广场六个街区远战争纪念歌剧院里，向签署联合国宪章的代表们发表讲话。这是妥协与让步、对观点和兴趣保持宽容的精神所结出的果实。现代的联合国广场。我们坚持我们的原则，永不放弃我们的目标。本·坦普顿于2004年制作了这些面临的问题。我于2011年11月17日录制这段音频，今天我在联合国广场录制了喷泉的声音并拍了照片。
The art market was being set up, and the water was flowing in the fountain that was marred by a bit of trash circling in the eddies, but nothing to grow test or unexpected. The yellow chain that cordoned off the fountain in 2004 is gone. And this morning with the art market being set up, I got a much stronger feel for the intention of the plaza than was evident when it was at its worst. But the big issues were still playing the scene. when it was at its worst. But the big issues were still playing the scene. Landscape Architect Lawrence Halpren, who designed UN Plaza and is featured in the piece, has since died.
艺术市场正在搭建中，喷泉里水流正潺潺流动，虽然回流的水涡中夹杂着一点垃圾，但也算不上令人厌恶或意料之外。2004年用以封锁喷泉的黄色链条已经消失了。今天早晨，随着艺术市场搭建起来，我对这个广场最初意图的感受比它处于最糟糕状态时要强烈得多。但重大的问题依然在这个场景中上演。当它处于最糟糕状态时。但重大的问题依然在这个场景中上演。设计了联合国广场并在片中出镜的景观设计师劳伦斯·哈尔普林此后已经去世。
If this is your first exposure to Halpren, I really recommend you look them up and check out his other work. He has absolutely revered in much of the landscape architecture community and the very principles of interactivity and engagement that worked to the detriment of human plaza yielded stunningly successful results in other places. So it's worth exploring more of its legacy if you're into that sort of thing, which I think you are, because you just listen to a half hour documentary about the failure of a public space.
如果你是第一次接触哈尔普林，我强烈建议你了解一下他并去看看他的其他作品。他在景观设计界备受尊崇，而他在人类广场的实践中导致了负面结果的互动与参与原则，在其他地方却取得了惊人的成功。所以如果你对这类事情感兴趣的话，探索他的更多遗产是值得的，我想你一定感兴趣，因为你刚刚听完了一场关于公共空间失败的半小时纪录片。
Which means you're a big old nerd like me. God love you. This episode of 99% Invisible was produced by Ben Tempton, and made possible with support from Lunar, making a difference with creativity. It's a project of KALW Local Public Radio 91.7 in San Francisco, the American Institute of Architects in San Francisco, in the center for architecture and design. To find out more, go to the website, it's 99% Invisible. Don't work. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这意味着你和我一样是个老书呆子。上帝保佑你。本期《99% Invisible》由本·坦普顿制作，并得到了Lunar的支持，通过创意创造不同。这是旧金山KALW地方公共广播电台91.7、旧金山美国建筑师学会以及建筑与设计中心的一个项目。欲了解更多信息，请访问我们的网站99% Invisible。别费力了。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。